[Music]
the NBA season going strong everyone
knows the best part of the NBA is during
timeouts when the mascots slam-dunk I
think that's what everybody likes the
most
we'll put applause in there later anyway
no no it doesn't count all right
everybody
no that's the thing I always love is
when the mascot slam dunk so we thought
would invite some mascots to the show
for a little fun okay unfortunately only
several of the worst mascots agreed to
participate so it's time once again for
our fifth annual NBA mascots that should
never dunk contest
[Applause]
[Music]
now to be honest these are terrible
mascots they should not dunk and I'm not
even sure what teams they're from but
that doesn't matter just accept the
premise so here we go
first up just in time for Valentine's
Day and Presidents Day it's Teddy
Roosevelt in a teddy
[Applause]
go for it teddy go
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
from my angle that was a horrifying
sight
of a truly great president okay here's
the next this is a terrible mascot it's
it's the Netflix envelope containing an
unwatched copy of The Tree of Life
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
almost like the movie itself didn't
quite make it okay here we go now let's
see how this bad idea the skydiving
clown
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
he's clearly dead I don't know why all
right here we go here's another awful
awful awful mascot now give it up
Linderman for the Twitter fail well the
Twitter fail well there is and go
Twitter farewell go
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
what's awful okay here's the next uh
next mascot the SNM guy who likes to be
bound with duct tape but whose partner
didn't have time to free him because she
had to go to work
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
he's been in that costume nine days here
we go ladies and gentlemen it's time for
disgraced Italian cruise ship captain of
the Costa Concordia captain Schettino
okay all right I'm not gonna dunk this
bar like you've never seen okay
[Applause]
[Music]
should have seen that coming and finally
then I really want to see this ladies
and gentlemen the Benihana chef
[Applause]
by Chef go
[Applause]
[Applause]